con nuestro segundo invitado el día
vamos a hablar de lo que ocurre en la
Ciudad de México esta cumbre de los
líderes de los países de América del
Norte hablamos de Canadá donde se
encuentra el Primer Ministro canadiense
Justin trudeo en representación de su
país también por supuesto del presidente
de Estados Unidos Joe biden y del
anfitrión el jefe de estado mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador los temas a
tratar en la mesa están evidentemente
las relaciones comerciales en este
tratado de libre comercio entre estos
tres países del Norte también la
migración un tema que ha estado pues muy
latente en estas últimas semanas estos
últimos meses y por supuesto la
seguridad saludamos entonces a nuestro
segundo invitado el día del skeneth él
es el presidente del Consejo canadiense
para las Américas las Américas Kenneth
Gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de martes en directo América de
Francia
24 y analizamos entonces un poco de esta
nueva reunión de los líderes de los
países de América del Norte
bueno Buen día es un placer estar con
ustedes Bueno la Cumbre siempre es una
lucha para hacer la Cumbre
unilateral en vez de una serie de
reuniones bilaterales no O sea Siempre
han sido más un tema de los Estados
Unidos con México los Estados Unidos con
Canadá yo creo que parte
de la idea que tiene en esa Cumbre es
intentar acercarse más a México y y
poder hacer más la relación entre México
y Canadá
Le quiero preguntar si a medida que han
pasado estas Cumbres realmente sí se ve
este acercamiento entre estos tres
países han mejorado las relaciones de de
estos tres gobiernos a medida que pasan
estas Cumbres o digamos que todo es de
entre comillas se ha quedado igual
Mira
los líderes de los tres países pueden
juntarse y hablar sobre temas sobre la
mesa o sea Recuerda que Durante los
cuatro años de Trump nunca todavía esa
Cumbre que normalmente es una Cumbre
anual
el año pasado empezaron de arrancar las
cumbres de nuevo es en sí una buen es un
buen desarrollo
yo creo que vamos a ver lo que sucede
después de las reuniones hoy en su
discurso de apertura ayer
empezó a hablar de una visión de todo
América Latina hablaba sobre Bolívar y
pidió a giovan que los Estados Unidos
haga algo Como hizo
de congreso etcétera etcétera entonces
vamos a ver si pueden hacer más O sea un
tema un poco menos amplio hablando de
como usted dice Raúl en temas de acceso
a mercado con México hay problemas o
Canadá y de Estados Unidos tienen pletos
sobre las medidas que ha tomado López
Obrador sobre todo en el campo
energético y también hay asuntos
regionales que han discutido para Canadá
por ejemplo sumamente importante hablar
de Haití y sobre todo el tema de
inmigración que es más un tema
bilateral entre México en los Estados
Unidos pero Canadá también tiene interés
en esas conversaciones también tenía un
tiene tiene algo que ver con ese tema
igual Sí eso le quería hablar que en la
migración un tema central en todas estas
conversaciones que se puede hablar
digamos los líderes en torno a la
migración o sobre todo que viene del sur
hacia el norte no estas nuevas medidas
migratorias tomadas por el gobierno del
presidente Joe biden para frenar
migración de pues las personas que
buscan llegar hacia el norte y también
como Canadá puede intervenir sobre todo
de manera económica para ayudar sobre
todo a México que es como el muro con
tensor de esto de esta flujo migratorios
sí
hay que entender que Canadá tiene un
sistema de migración muy distinta
podemos decir sistema relativamente
ordenado y o sea y la gente encarga en
su sistema de seleccionar emigrantes
etcétera etcétera el año pasado había
más de
500.000 emigrantes así a Canadá o sea el
el el el la cantidad más grande en la
historia de Canadá al fin de día el El
como usted dice el tema de la Muralla y
todo eso en el sur en la frontera de
entre México y Estados Unidos
en sí y y los Estados Unidos pero al fin
de día este Canadá no quiere que que
venga un flujo tan grande de inmigrantes
sobre todo no documentados hacia Canadá
entonces Canadá también tenía interés
hay que entender con Canadá que su
política como dije antes es un poco
distinto verdad ha aceptado muchos
emigrantes de Siria y Ucrania por
ejemplo cuando los Estados Unidos no
querían hacer eso quería hacer eso
entonces son políticas distintas pero
hasta cierto punto Sí hay hay los
resultados que quieren los Estados
Unidos
un tema muy importante la seguridad
ligada al narcotráfico en estos últimos
días también vimos esta recaptura de uno
de los hijos de Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán
en la ciudad de Culiacán todos los
estragos que dejó este operativo también
más de 15 17 muertos que hubo en esta
ciudad cómo están trabajando estos tres
países para mitigar el narcotráfico
sobre todo la violencia que se vive en
México
vamos a ver qué más medidas pueden tomar
o sea eso es algo Bastante serio
bastante serio en principio para la
gente de México la seguridad de México
por supuesto tiene ramificaciones para
inversión y en otros temas también más
medidas no sabemos lo que lo que lo que
pueden hacer Vamos a ver lo que dicen
Pues al fin de día lo que diría yo es es
una conversación similar que lo que está
haciendo intentando hacer el presidente
y Petro en Colombia sobre otros sistemas
de regular las drogas sería muy esa
clase conversación sería muy oportuna
pero pero eso no va a llegar yo lo dudo
claro